bella tutti ragazzi e bambini che sono
video sono pari j
oggi siamo su dungeon nightmares due
perché c'è anche il 2 visto ciò che ho
fatto l'uno intera era il gioco dove è
nato zio bob in poche parole c'è da dove
inizia a tokyo a trovare zio bobby
quindi appena uscito il 2 che poi è una
demo volevo farlo assolutamente non ora
è quasi di zio bobby perché boom
ah no sono sveglia bene era una sveglia
perché mi sembrava una bomba ecco qua
tempo come facciamo tutte le mattine che
andiamo a scuola non ci si alza la
mattina e si va se vai in un posto di
merda è la stessa cosa anche bello tosto
televisore full hd ci guardiamo avatar
lista merda permesso sentite io sono
uscito dal bagno devo andare a scuola
grazie c'è per caso la scuola di quasi
300 8 sì sì ma velista alcamo tali non
ceffone la madonna prof
non trova classe non c'è la clave e
allora [ __ ] non è permesso bidelli
bidelli dove cazzo vado io tutto voi di
qua questa è una bella stava in voglio
proprio ad andarsi sua porta bellissimo
giorno sentivo sapri
ma a bocciare la ma il sole che spacca
le pietre a luglio ragazzi con tanto
bello la scienza terme manichino ogni
tanto più giusto per ascensori nel 2014
sempre più tecnologici la sm forma per
ok
buongiorno file di arti fa che oggi
siamo tutti di buon umore quindi prendo
la candela mi fate vedere come la mappa
che non sa che cos'è
quindi io io posso andare barbato di qua
per bongiorno sentite york sono uno
studente vanno in classico sesso schifo
non sia mai che adorava perito sembra
che siano vecchi vestiti si ok sto
prendendo delle candele acacus un quadro
l'immagine sun
senta boom
ciao ma per caso sai dov'è la mia classe
96 passata costituta si vede che era in
ritardo la gara tutti i capitali sanati
cazzo di bidermann perché non aggiustate
le tubature ma perché si muoverà sta
cosa l'ho vista ragazzi ma stanno
facendo educazione fisica di sopra io
uscirei un attimo di qua perché dai
cazzo scuola laica scuole che io mi
iscrivo al professionale mi stacco da
qui perché [ __ ] mi piace proprio
quando li le belle idee di giocare a
sputtanati assurde allora fatemi capire
una di qua bella questa porta proprio
invoglia ad andare di qua bellissimo ma
[ __ ] piace soprattutto il fatto
che io vado importa è che mi fu sorpreso
13 settembre
ecco vedete che inizia proprio il giorno
in cui inizia la scuola non era uno
scherzo che la cosa sono io che mi ero
io che volevano mania per fermi che mi
sembrava qualcuno dall'altra parte però
pino e non c'è nessuno bene sentite un
po b lo sapevo già c'eri anche tu brutto
stronzo scottano lo sapevo che ci
mancava che non lo mettessero pure nel
due bellissimi
di quasi ora devo andare la sinistra
perfetto e scott hodes io mi guarda che
per di sangue fa attenzione stato bello
rivederti però [ __ ] che posto di
me allora di qua
ecco di cosa ci sono ancora da perfetto
bello bello scoprire posti nuovi
non poteva esserci le margherite [ __ ]
zio bob la perché adesso dove rompere il
cazzo tutte le volte ne va a fan culo
[ __ ] ascolta 0 ci siamo molto
capito io e te ne devi startene
affanculo che io non è che posso dare è
solo uno scheletro ma sto cazzo mi hai
anche una cosa molto sexy brion dei
liquami sono fa vigier senti trovato zio
bobby però non si è fatto che non so che
non entrare nella stanza 313 1 st e stai
tranquillo che io non è che stamattina
mi ero alzato con l'intenzione di dire
poverina stanza 300 30 ma chi può andare
qua sotto muoio naso nome muoio quindi
non ci vado e che passa le giornate o
buttarmi nei pozzi interisti che cosa
stai facendo zio fatemi andare via
allora l'ho fatto su cosa qui o madre
ossigenata ok perfetto non era meglio
sono la prima o me ne vado a [ __ ] a
si riscalda zio stai stai lì perché
allora brown bello giocare solo perché
ci sono gli ambientazioni che putin
vogliono ad andare avanti bellissimo
fino adesso abbiamo imparato che non
dobbiamo entrare nella stanza a 313
poche parole belle non ci volevo entrare
comunque livelli che lo trovai 31
ottobre 2008 qualcuno sembra essersi
perso qui devo andare ancora nella mia
classe
trovato permesso sto cercando la mia
classica scontate legali non è che posso
andare avanti così sono tutte uguali si
va fuori
[Musica]
la tua madre infatti aprire queste cose
prima di morire ammazzati in qualche
modo sì sì l'ho trovato ad una sirena
della polizia ha trovato la chiave della
stanza 313 trova l'uscita non ci voglio
andare in cosa abbiate pazienza sto bene
qui dove sono
continua a correre subito un attimo io
non è che posso far stabilità in mezzo
ai corridoi del gatto ok ogni tanto si
sentono stesse culate al secondo me
qualcuno in palestra che cade di culo
tipo qualcuno che pesa 300 kg sentite se
per caso non trovate ecco l'ho trovata
sì quando will to exit gira ma non è ok
giro di non è chiami arriva qualcuno là
dietro mentre gira già fatta già fatta
bastardi temevo ma rimaste zio bobin
faccia in qualche modo non lo so è stata
una città bellissima perché io no e
basta cazzo no un altro giorno di qua
che palle oggi è martedì brutto giorno
prima era lunedì era brutto adesso
ancora più brutto è la chiave per la
stanza 313 sì ma ci ha scritto di non
entrarci perché ti devo andare per forza
dove cazzola 303 non c'è altre 113 e di
400 313 non so che cazzo se cadeva bene
tanto è il peggio di adele di quella
scuola di nociglia ricreazione giochiamo
palla da io sto in porta dai facciamo
così è un provino di victor cos'è per me
è no mito hai visto parla di merda la
lavagna si toglie io ho chiesto
gentilmente se mi toglie la palla nuovo
però quasi quasi me la tolgo la sola
giorno stavo scherzando permessi ma
[ __ ] 9 il bello che non c'è
neanche la musica
la terza ondata di stato da bambina c'è
una bambina che correva non si sa dove è
finita ma portami bar bambina del cazzo
quella che è un pizzico di di
allenamento ci vorrebbe però tanto per
cambiare bello sto giorni pieni giuro
che è uno dei giochi più belli che abbia
mai giocato
ogni volta che questo rumore non capisco
ho trovato lo jan ci ho messo cinque
secondi a trovare altre vecchia vetra
ceduto la sostanza 304 perché era 311
non bastava vero caffè un pokemon sta
minchia di valvola delle palle qualcuno
ragazzi mi spiega perchè trovo delle
club che cazzo ok non è che so quali
sono quelli che fanno palestra kakà anni
tutti ragazzi così stop ma tu sei per
caso una delle ballerine di michael
jackson
no no è uscita sì sì no no no no no no
no no no veloce della guerra sta meglio
è tutta un'altra è brutta più di te ce
la facciamo a tirare sta cazzo di leva
in occasione di conto un po di
fondotinta per favore ditemi voi se
nonostante la il posto di merda devo
anche rifarmi delle livelli perché muoio
d'armi è che botta di culo ho trovato
artefatto la prima cazzo di scatola che
ho aperto mi chiamano questo allora io
sto quale il peggio tradizione tua madre
fa le porte ma quelle brutte ragazzi si
è cacciato già fuori che cos'è che cosa
è successo perché c'era un bambino
dentro questa cosa mi mancavano i
bambini che uscivano dalle scatole
questa è questa mia nuova quella ladra
che ti giuro madonna gli schiaffi a chi
ha fatto sto gioco ragazzi mi fate
capire dove devo andare io sto aprendo
forte a caso perché non sto capendo
[ __ ] [ __ ]
lo sapevo lo avrei scommesso se cazzo
fatemi uscire
si si si fa mi gira questo schifo se mi
arriva qualcuno mi chiama una bottiglia
in faccia giura ragazzi bassi e stato
orribile bastano né con solamente per
[Musica]
qualcuno apriva le porte a caso prodotte
sega per cosa ragazzi e che posso
concludere qui per adesso visto che è
stato emotivo d'ora ma no è finita come
non detto
thank you for plague lo è già compilate
short view dungeon nightmares civile
ragazzi è stato divertente giocare
questa cosa mi è piaciuto ragazzi che ho
sete lasciate un commento vi piace io
vado a cambiarmi i pantaloni anche pace
di facebook e come limitato la
trascrizione se dovresti discrete io
dovrei anche prendere un telecomando che
non lo trovo però non vada prendo perché
ho paura quindi ragazzi di tudor vito
con questa cosa bella
ecco forse dovresti di scarpe che ci
vediamo nei prossimi do vero ragazzi